when guardians of the galaxy had
theaters in 2014 audiences immediately
fell in love with Drax the destroyer
played to perfection by Dave Bautista
Drax was Batista's Hollywood breakout
but this wasn't his first taste of
celebrity years before stepping into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Dave Bautista
was one of the most famous wrestlers in
the WWE known simply as Batista but how
did he go from the WWE to the MCU a
rough start
Dave Batista grew up in Washington DC
abandoned by his father
Batista credits his mother with pulling
them through difficult times and she
eventually took the family to San
Francisco as Batista grew older he found
himself involved with a pretty bad crowd
in addition to failing grades for teesta
was stealing cars by age 13 by the age
of 17 he was living on his own
working as a lifeguard before winding up
as a bouncer as he neared 30 Batista was
earning $100 a night in LA nightclubs
handling angry drunks while trying to
support his two kids finally fed up with
the way things were going
Batista decided it was time to make some
changes and tried to get into the
wrestling game however even though he
stood well over 6 feet tall and weighed
in at 340 pounds
Batista failed to impress when he
auditioned at WCW power plant but the
man who would be drags wasn't about to
give up instead he set his eye on a
different prize the WWE going prior as
someone had been getting into scrapes
since age 9 tossing guys around in a
cage seemed like a natural fit for
Batista he signed up with the wild
Samoan training center in Allentown and
after learning the ropes he made his way
to Ohio Valley Wrestling a feeder system
for World Wrestling Entertainment
Batista played a character called
Leviathan a demon raised from the Ohio
River the wrestler later described the
role as little cheesy but still cool
finally in 2002 WWE came calling
transforming Leviathan into deacon
batista a suit-wearing henchman to a
heel named reverend d-von admittedly
Batista was upset about the outfit as it
covered his body his strongest assets
eventually he dropped the Deacon bit and
became simply Batista joining up with
Triple H and Ric Flair to form the
wrestling super group known as evolution
soon Batista was strumming down with
Triple H at WrestleMania 21 where he
defeated his opponent
claim the world heavyweight championship
in 2005 in addition to setting a record
by holding the belt for 282 days Batista
would regain championship glory five
more times but ballpit ISTA was making a
name for himself not everything was
quite so happy behind the scenes leaving
the WWE despite his rise to stardom
Batista wasn't completely happy with his
newfound fame he started butting heads
with WWE owner Vince McMahon and grew
unhappy with the promotion's new PG era
the company brass wanted to tone down
the adult themes but Batista preferred
keeping things edgy Batista also didn't
feel like the WWE was giving him enough
opportunities outside the company he
wanted to score some acting gigs like
his WWE coworker John Cena but the
company wasn't interested in giving him
any juicy parts certain guys were
getting opportunities that I wasn't
getting and I wasn't real cool with that
so I left to accomplish certain things
feeling unloved by their promotion
Batista called it quits in 2010 and
while he returned for a few guest
appearances it seems he's largely put
his WWE days behind him getting started
as an actor before joining Marvel
Batista took some smaller roles playing
himself an Australian soap opera
neighbours and appearing in an episode
of Smallville but the acting bug didn't
really bite until he played a role in
the straight-to-dvd action flick wrong
side of town according to the budding
thespian he absolutely loved working on
the film but Bautista also had one
little problem as he told both movies
death I thought since I had done
on-camera stuff in WWE this was going to
be the same that it would be the same
stuff but then I realized how hard it
was deciding he had to get better
Bautista hide himself an acting coach
and started learning on the job he
learned from Billy Zane in the Scorpion
King 3 Dominic Purcell in House of the
Rising Sun and the future Guardians
co-star Vin Diesel and Riddick and all
that hard work eventually paid off when
director James Gunn started assembling a
ragtag bunch of space heroes to guard
the galaxy becoming Drax if you land a
major role in the MCU you've pretty much
got it made in the shade so it makes
sense up at easter was really anxious
about learning the parts of Drax the
destroyer a super literal bruiser
but Easter admitted to Wyatt that he was
terrified when trying out for the parts
after all this was the biggest projected
ever auditioned for but while he might
have been nerve
on the inside you wouldn't know by
watching a screen test auditioning
alongside Chris Pratt's Batista appears
pretty chill and incredibly natural as
the otherworldly assassin okay I got you
back I won't touch you again that's the
last time I touch you despite his long
show business career for teesta was
still pretty nervous when he showed up
for work on guardians of the galaxy he
described that first day as
nerve-wracking but eventually he started
feeling at home with his Marvel co-stars
describing Zoe Saldana and Chris Pratt
as world-class actors but the real
challenge was to make obsessions it
usually took four to six hours for the
makeup crew to get Bautista ready for
the day he wasn't too crazy about
spending day after day in all that
makeup eventually it would start to
irritate the skin and he told Collider
it made him quote constantly filled
dirty as for the finished product
Bautista was pretty critical of his
performance at first but as he watched
the film unfold he was totally drawn
into the movie life after guardians
since he saved the galaxy the first time
around Bautista has been keeping himself
pretty busy around Hollywood naturally
the actor reprised his role as tracks
and guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and
Avengers infinity war but Bautista has
been doing a lot more than just Marvel
work in 2015 he played mr. Hanks
Inspector Blofeld's terrifying henchmen
who gives James Bond one of the best
brawls in the entire double-oh-seven
franchise the man also put his martial
art skills to work in kick boxer
vengeance playing an undefeated body by
the name of Tong PO and put in a
supporting turn in Blade Runner 2049
before co-starring with Sylvester
Stallone in a skate planter the WWE's
lost was Tinseltown's gained and it
looks like Batista will be winning
hearts and bashing skulls on the silver
screen for a very long time
[Music]